Magneto and Hyperion kill the Marvel
Universe this story is amazing so this
basically opens up with the death of
storm little bit of explanation here so
this takes place in a story called
Exiles and in effect the Exiles are a
team of various superheroes from
different realities who have been
brought together and they travel the
Multiverse quote unquote fixing
different universes usually it involves
them just killing people right but the
fact remains that every time a member of
the Exiles dies a new person is sent in
to replace them and you never know who
that person is going to be you don't
know if it's going to be like an
alternate version of Magneto or Cyclops
Wolverine or something like that we end
up finding out the person that's been
sent in here is King Hyperion we're not
going to get his origin story in this
video but this guy's origin is amazing
CU he basically killed everybody in his
own Universe It's pretty dope but he's
like the closest you get to Superman in
Marvel Comics the fact is in this new
universe that they've been sent to
basically all the X-Men are dead and
pretty much all the superheroes are dead
because Magneto had incited a war
between humanity and the mutant
population and in fact you end up
switching to asteroid in which
historically speaking in Marvel Comics
is kind of a base of operations that
Magneto's used on and off again before
its eventual destruction in the main
Marvel Universe and in effect what he's
doing here in talking to Petro of course
Quicksilver as you guys know him as well
as Forge who despite having all this
history and all that kind of cool stuff
is basically the X-Men's version of Tony
Stark right in terms of what he can do
that between all of them working
together just the few mutants that are
left in existence here they're basically
taking this massive Earth killing
asteroid and firing it at Earth right
like to literally wipe out all life on
the planet and a lot of it's just
because Magneto is just being a dick if
we're being honest and it's one of these
things where Quicksilver actually tells
him like there's still some mutants left
on earth right that were just now
picking up of course some of them in the
Exiles and some of them were also other
mutants that are in hiding that Humanity
doesn't know about that we'll talk about
here in a little bit but were the
questions asked of Magneto like do we
want to go and grab them his response no
just end it now leave Xavier and his
brood to die among the humans they
insisted on protecting the same
neanderthals who hated them so Charles
was given every opportunity to join us
to destroy Humanity by our side but he
refused me and died by their hand as I
always said he would we'll destroy the
humans and the mutants stupid enough to
stand beside them all deserve the same
fate so it's one of these crazy things
because at that moment you switch over
to spider now spider's cool man he's
basically a version of Peter Parker from
an alternate universe who was a mass
murderer he was senten to 67 consecutive
life sentences but he's basically an
alternate version of Peter Parker who
got the Symbian it's really cool cuz
like all he wants to do is destroy stuff
and so you kind of have a moment of a
reprieve where like the characters kind
of like hang out right like Carol
Danvers is just like totally smitten
with Hyperion like she comes on to him
and she's like hey like you want to
touch naughty bits and he's like sure I
guess right so the two of them start
going at it and then like when they get
done she's like wanting to have Pillow
Talk and hyperion's like hey do you want
to play the airplane game and she's like
what's that and he's like well you take
off it's just one of those things
God doesn't want to have anything to do
with her right but then you end up
finding out that they're both being
watched by this universe's version of
kitty Pride which is kind of creepy but
she was basically in hiding from like
Sentinels who had shown up here and
basically started eradicating all the
different X-Men of course Colossus shows
up on the scene but again this is
Colossus as part of the Exiles team he's
not from this universe so they've
basically been sent here to eradicate
all the mutants on this planet including
including Magneto that's the actual
charge of their mission as it was given
to them by the time broker the time
broker in the whole Exiles Mythos is
like this guy who exists out there
seemingly beyond space and time or at
the very end of all things you do find
out who he is and there is a whole story
behind it but I'm not going to tell you
guys in case you all end up wanting me
to cover the Exiles Comics which are
really really good if I'm being honest
and we'll probably end up seeing them in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe because of
the Multiverse Saga but it's one of
those things where like because that's
the mission that's given to them
hyperion's like no we're not going to
kill anybody he's like instead we're
going to take over this world we're
literally going to enslave what's left
of the human race if there's anything
left at all Magneto's left anybody at
all and then we're just going to take
over the entire world unto ourselves now
a lot of that is kind of predicated on
the Unknown Origin of Hyperion at that
point in time later on in the series
with issue number 65 you end up finding
out that he literally killed everybody
in his own Universe up to an including
galatis right like they're all gone but
eventually like Earth gets nuked by what
few humans are left hoping to destroy
him and then basically he's just like
there as part of a empty radiated husk
of a planet where he's whisked away by
the time broker and brought onto the
Exiles so yeah I guess we basically
covered his Orin in this video but the
fact remains here right like there's no
concern for Magneto or any of those guys
more so than that vision of course being
an Android and really following the
orders of the time broker to a t
overhears the conversation of Hyperion
and tries to overrule him at which point
Hyperion just incinerates this guy on
the spot right and is like does anybody
else want to argue like does anybody
else want to debate with me and
everybody's just kind of like no not
really because one of the big things
that you guys will realize is that these
different variations of the characters
that we know in a lot of ways lack
pretty much all the moral fortitude of
traditional superheroes I wouldn't go so
far as to call them cowards but I would
say they don't really function the same
way that we're used to and so what's
really cool about this is that following
this whole statement it's like okay
let's do the thing and then at the same
time like the asteroid is fired from
asteroid M and is on a collision course
for Earth where it will collide and
eradicate all life on the planet within
24 hours at that point you switch over
to Washington DC and what you end up
finding out is that it wasn't simply
just the mutant population on Earth that
was destroyed in this war that Magneto
incited it was also like pretty much all
the Avengers Iron Man's dead ant-man's
dead Daredevil's dead presumably black
Bolt's dead because he and humans suck I
mean why wouldn't they die but the fact
is like all these different superheroes
have all been killed off but then you
have a guy who just comes running in
talking to like the higher ups in
Washington and it's like okay Magneto
did it he fired the asteroid we've got
24 hours while that's going on you
transition to the Pentagon and you end
up finding out that the Sentinel program
is alive and well and while the
Sentinels were responsible ible for
destroying a good portion of the
superheroes on Earth they don't
currently have a way to get to Magneto
on asteroid imp so they're basically
building a sort of spaceborn prototype
of Sentinel that can get to asteroid M
and then basically either obliterate the
asteroid itself because Magneto can't
really breathe in space for too long
certainly not enough to get himself back
to Earth or they can somehow use their
non-metallic properties to invade the
asteroid and then destroy Magneto the
kicker about all this is that you have
Hyperion and his guys who show up at the
Pentagon and just start incinerating and
Blasting all these Sentinels to Pieces
they literally come out of nowhere right
now Carol Danvers ever smitten with
Hyperion right and just unable to take a
hint it's just like following him around
like a lost puppy dog and so like she's
getting attacked by these Sentinels and
she's like hey like can you help me for
a second and he's just like I'm busy
I've got more important things to do
than deal with the whims and wants of a
girl who can't take a hint and does not
realize she's not Mrs Wright She's just
misses right now and so it's one of
those things where he's just kind of
like you know whatever so like he ends
up just letting these sels attack her
which of course it doesn't kill Carol
damers but what he does do is he hits
the main core and that actually shuts
down all the Sentinels then he chastises
Carol Danvers right and he's just like
you need to learn to think bigger right
like the reality here is sure I could
have gone after those Sentinels that
were attacking you but by attacking the
main core their power source is gone
they can't function anymore which
includes the ones that are attacking you
so literally Sentinels just start
falling out of the sky now the
government doesn't know what to do in
response to this they have no clue
what's going on even the X-Men or I
guess the Exiles don't really even know
what's going on but they do come to the
realization quite readily that Hyperion
did exactly what he said he was going to
do which was basically eliminate the
entirety of the Sentinel threat because
one of the things to keep in mind here
is that with this future or this
universe functioning the way that it is
it really would just turn into days a
future past where the Sentinels
themselves become self-aware and then
they in turn just start mass-producing
themselves by thousands right you know
some base 10 number right you know
20,000 Sentinels you know or you know a
million Sentinels that just exist across
the world where the numbers are just too
overwhelming for any superheroes that
may be left following that they end up
basically making their way to what's
called storm City and storm city is
literally the last refuge for any and
everybody who is trying to survive this
war between the human population and the
mutant population in the sense they
operate under the protection of storm
but the other cool thing about this is
that Hyperion emerges from the White
House and basically declares the
President right this guy's dead and gone
like there is no more president of the
United States anymore not only that he's
met by the arrival of Magneto now the
kicker about this right is that Hyperion
says this world is mine now Magneto I
will protect it from whatever threat you
think you might post the response to
Magneto I have launched an asteroid
which is now plummeting towards the
surface of the Earth I came here to
offer you an opportunity for salvation
with us in space but I see now that you
might prefer to rule over the ashes of a
dead World reconsider and join us your
genetic equals or remain and die the
choice is yours and so like Hyperion
just kind of looks at him for a second
and then smirks right cuz this guy could
easily withstand a planet killing
asteroid he says and I offer your
Brotherhood a choice stop the asteroid
save my planet and remain with me or die
and so it's just one of those things
where it's like get him right like
Magneto sends his guys after Hyperion
now in that moment right we transition
back over to storm City where you've got
Gambit and these other members of the
Exiles as well as Kitty pride and
they're met by the vanisher now the
vanisher is a very old character in
Marvel Comics in fact he's one of the
first early villains that the X-Men
fought when the X-Men were introduced to
Marvel Comics itself he's basically a
teleporter he's not really a teleporter
that can go to like any distance or any
range he is relatively limited but he is
the method to get in and out of storm
City if you were to just like walk up on
it and try to enter into it that would
never happen right like you would
literally be incinerated by just the
field of power that storms emanating
around this place not only that once you
switch back to Magneto and Hyperion they
have this kind of standoff going on
wolver rain is sent in and wolver rain
is made to understand his place in the
bigger picture because literally like
Hyperion says I don't want to kill your
minions Magneto I just want to kill you
and wolver rain's just like the road to
him leads through me the response of
Hyperion fine and he just incinerates
Wolverine on the spot and Magneto is
just kind of a little flabbergasted
Mystique doesn't know what to say
because she's just like dude that guy
was indestructible and so Magneto just
like attack him right like Rogue Iceman
deal with this guy and they're just kind
of like I mean you know look I mean this
dude killed wolver rain and here's the
thing man like reconsider right I mean
you know let's stop the asteroid and
then we can rule the world right I mean
that kind of a thing right so like
they're basically just kind of like I'm
not fighting that guy right like that's
not going to happen and so literally the
forces of of Magneto are just kind of
dissipating and disappearing around him
Mystique is seemingly the only one left
so the response of Hyperion stop the
asteroid or I will implode your head and
Magneto's response is to lash out at
Hyperion and so literally in this moment
he says I will tear your heart out the
iron in your blood will boil Through
Your Skin the response of Hyperion I am
not of this Earth not of any Earth and
my blood contains no iron he incinerates
Mystique on the spot destroys Magneto
ship grabs Magneto and flies him into
space he says give up this garbage and
face the inevitable Magneto you cannot
defeat me and where Magneto responds in
saying everyone has an Achilles heel the
response of Hyperion only Achilles had
an Achilles heel I cannot be stopped and
so he just tells him like stop this
asteroid and maybe I'll care what you
have to say but Magneto refuses right he
just declines the offer he will not stop
the asteroid even when Hyperion says
stop the asteroid Magneto or I'll toss
your pieces across the globe Magneto
just says no and so Hyperion kills him
on the spot and then at that point it's
just Hyperion facing this asteroid as
this thing comes crashing into Earth now
jumping back to storm city in Colorado
when the Exiles show up Storm
immediately just kisses Gambit just
because of the fact that in this reality
storm and Gambit were basically in love
this is an alternate version of that
Gambit but still she wasn't really able
to say goodbye to her Gambit so it kind
of helps her to get past this as best
she can more so than that the whole idea
of like the asteroid heading towards
Earth in a lot of ways storm just
doesn't want to leave and the reason why
is because she promised the people here
safety and the reality is she can't get
them all off of this place even vanisher
is just like I don't know if I have the
ability to teleport all these people to
asteroid m in time in order for them to
survive there's a better than fair
chance most are going to die here and so
storms response then I will die with
them right that's basically it and so
what you get is hyperion showing up on
the scene with Rogue who he probably did
the dirty with at some point and
literally says like this is our plan
right Rogue has the ability to siphon
people's Powers what Rogue and I are
going to do is we're going to go to the
asteroid we're going to destroy this
thing and then we're going to conquer
this world and the world will become
mine that's something that I hope you're
noticing here is he keeps saying like
mine I'm going to conquer the world I
will be the ruler of Earth the Exiles
are kind of looking at it you know
they're hearing him say that and it's
like yes I mean obviously he means us so
like we are going to rule the world and
that kind of a thing no because this guy
absolutely loses his mind right it goes
nuts here in a minute and so what ends
up happening is when Rogue touches him
right that vanisher uses his powers to
teleport everybody to asteroid in right
and so it's just Rogue and it is uh
Hyperion who are left behind she touches
this guy absorbs his powers and then
just kind of realizes just how capable
he is now this is an important thing to
grasp here because this introduces the
idea at least at this point in time when
the story was written outside of
Avengers annual number 10 I guess where
she touched Thor and then became worthy
that like she can basically duplicate
the powers of anybody even if they're
not a mutant right Carol Danvers Miss
Marvel kind of solidified that right but
it's one of those things where it's kind
of hit and miss it just sort of stacks
on the idea that this is possible and so
essentially like of course you know
Quicksilver is kind of dealt with
readily and Forge is dealt with readily
because you know they're both still
there on asteroid M but for the main
asteroid itself h ion and Rogue are
blasting this thing with their vision
and the idea is to break it into smaller
pieces so that the massive piece won't
crash into Earth and obliterate
everything right the smaller pieces will
cause a lot of damage but at the end of
the day the Earth Will Survive and
everything will more or less be okay for
those who could survive the whole thing
what's crazy about this is that as you
guys know when Rogue absorbs Powers it
only works for a certain amount of time
so hyperion's Powers start wearing off
and she was like reach for me I need a
recharge and he's just like no and he's
like it's pointless so he just leaves he
just leaves this girl to die she's
incinerated by the asteroid and that's
it because this thing comes crashing
down into the planet and because of
Magneto's actions everybody on Earth is
basically eradicated the entirety of
Earth's population is destroyed so all
that's left of the human and mutant
population is what's on asteroid M that
that's it and so you basically pick up
with Colossus and kitty Pride who were
looking to try to find a way to get back
to Earth potentially survive right if
there's some kind of a bunker they can
get to I don't know why it would make
sense to get back to Earth they just
kind of panic and it's like get us to an
escape pot but the reality is like
Hyperion shows back up again and he's
like nope now we're going to complete
the mission and so he literally goes to
try to kill Kitty Pride Colossus jumps
in the way he punches this guy through
the ship itself right literally punches
a hole through the thing Kenny Pride
goes with him so they both suffocate out
in space and then you have him showing
up he goes after Gambit right he grabs
Forge throws Forge through a hole in the
side right so Forge is dead now Iceman
patches the hole up but then he goes
after Quicksilver and kills quicks on
the spot he literally just starts
massacring everybody right like Peter
Parker Spider Carnage kills vanquisher
by stabbing him through the chest and
even when Gambit tries to go after this
guy right like him and storm basically
end up getting banisher out of there as
fast as they can because while he's not
able to like teleport them to a whole
different location he is able to
teleport them seemingly just out of the
room but in the midst of all that the
Incredible Hulk and firear from an
alternate reality appear here now
contrary to what you might think they're
not here to fight Hyperion or at least
not yet they're here because they're
replacing the people who have died the
Colossus is dead and vision is dead and
so they're here to take their places and
so it's one of those things where it's
like okay now we basically deal with the
mission right like we start killing all
the mutants that are left here now
what's crazy is because storms lost
everything of value to her she basically
asked Gambit to help her end all her
living which he does right it's really
more of a mercy thing than anything else
but it's done out of love because while
neither of them have spent any
meaningful time together and neither of
them are truly in love this version of
Gambit had fallen in love with a
different version of storm and this
version of storm had fallen in love with
a different version of Gambit and so
through those relationships they had
they do respect and care about each
other enough to allow this to happen
right for Gambit to go through with it
and he's actually struggling pretty hard
because he loses yet another storm right
another woman that he could have
potentially had a life with and then
like Hyperion shows up and starts making
fun of him while he's grieving he was
like you know I knew you'd come around
Gambit you're just too sensible man it's
pretty brutal right it's pretty hardcore
but because of the fact that they are
working for the time Brokers that Gambit
along with everybody else are teleported
away to their next mission meanwhile
everybody who was here all the humans on
Earth all the mutants that remained
They're All Dead literally because of
the actions of Magneto and by extension
the actions of iperion the entirety of
the Marvel Universe was killed with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end let me know what you
think about Exiles down in the comment
section and I will catch you all later
peace